it's time for our scene and unseen
segment we expose the big cultural
stories of the day with a hint of
politics for that we turn to fox news
contributor raymond arroyo all right ray
you closely watched the president's
afghanistan response
well it didn't take long laura the
president's stilted halting address
about the situation he helped create was
clearly written by somebody else it was
not only inaccurate at times but the
delivery like the policy was incoherent
american troops are performing this
mission
our current military mission
we shorten time
limited
scope
our mission in afghanistan is taking
many missteps made many missteps over
the past two decades
yeah missteps is definitely the operable
word of the day laura so much for
foreign policy being the white house
strength it took biden days to respond
to the fall of afghanistan in person
jinsaki his press secretary never even
returned emails everybody's on vacay the
only thing the white house offered
initially was this a picture of biden at
camp david allegedly zooming with
national security and intelligence
officials now former cia members pointed
out this is could be a huge mistake
because they may have outed cia
operatives and individuals at the doha
station who were photographed there on
the wall others gripe that this might be
a stock photo since the times on the
clocks aren't correct and some speculate
that this is a staged photo and biden
was watching something entirely
different
ladies and gentlemen
it's the lawrence well show hello
i'm julia child
welcome to this volume of our video book
the way to cook
[Music]
well it's a pity he wasn't watching
jeopardy laura he could have taken
foreign policy disasters for 400. uh the
biggest problem here is to go back to
camp david to go on vacation after this
little address as if nothing's going on
to continue your recreating joe biden is
literally not at home when it comes to
this foreign policy crisis yeah that
picture was um
it was a troubling photo raymond the
the the blue tight uh polo shirt look i
mean we have we have people losing their
lives clinging to a u.s airport
transport planes air force and you
weren't a i don't know
i if i i keep saying if trump had done
the exact same thing with the same
scenes playing out at the bagram air
force base they would have slaughtered
him and there would have been
one of the most amazing things today
laura was beyond the dramatic pictures
of chaos in afghanistan is the media
coverage of this i mean this is what
parallel realities look like you've
heard of the marvel multiverse this is
the media multiverse watch it's been a
relatively
peaceful if you like a process they
haven't had to fire a lot of shots there
hasn't been a lot of bloodshed in kabul
it was a pretty straightforward takeover
they have maintained today as far as we
can see
calm an order inside the capital they're
just chanting death to america but they
seem friendly at the same time
very friendly lord look i've been in
egypt with the muslim brotherhood nearby
i know what it's like for a reporter in
that situation but you can't distort
your reporting because of your personal
safety you know go to a secure spot file
your report there i'm sorry the taliban
are not friendly they're threatening
families they're beating women in the
streets they're raping girls right now
at this hour they're murderous thugs
driven by a twisted religious ideology
you heard none of that today you would
have sworn these people were
interviewing liquilessa after the fall
of communism
yeah there's some of the interviews that
i saw of the taliban spokesman today
they were they were
they've been more aggressive with
republican senators than they were with
the taliban spokesman and the split
screen i'm like well you don't you can
be a little rough around the edges no i
mean i'm slightly exaggerating but i
don't know i mean it they they
yeah well one of the questions msnbc
asked that taliban spokesman was are you
going to let women vote oh yeah they're
going to let them lead the party and
wear halter tops taliban lives under
sharia law they impose that everywhere
they go welcome to reality and that
should be reported lord and it isn't no
the raymond the rules-based
international order i'm sure the taliban
the taliban
all right raymond thank you hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else